لذا، نعم، أعتقد أن كلا الناديين
ليسا في الأماكن التي يتوقعان
أن يكونا فيها، ولا أستطيع حقًا أن أقول الكثير
عن ذلك، نعم
دعنا نقول إنني أعرفهما جيدًا،
وأحترمهما كثيرًا لأكون صادقًا، فأنا أحب
كلاهما
عندما أكون في  إنهم
أشخاص جيدون حقًا ومديرون رائعون كلاهما
ولكن لا تزال الأمور يمكن أن تسير في الاتجاه الخاطئ،
وبعد ذلك عندما يعتقد صناع القرار في
النادي أن عليهم التغيير
ويتغيرون،
فكروا جيدًا، فنحن جميعًا نقبل هذا الجزء من
العمل
وهذا  إنه إلى حد كبير ولكن
هذا أسبوع غريب أود أن
أقول إن كونتي
كان في نهاية الأسبوع الماضي،
لذا،
يدخل الموسم في جزء حاسم
والناس
يخافون من عدم الوصول إلى أهدافهم وهذا كل شيء،
أنا لا أفعل ذلك  أعرف ما إذا كان لديك ثلاثة
ولديك الفرصة لسؤال
الأشخاص الحاسمين وماذا سيقولون
عنه وخاصة الاثنين
ولكن أود أن أقول بالنسبة للأربعة الذين
ذكرتهم الآن
في مستقبل إدارة كرة القدم لا يزال
مشرقًا لذا فهو ليس كذلك  كارثة، إنها مجرد
موقف ربما لا
يعجبهم ولكني قلت جزءًا من العمل